do you have been to also have
constipation advice you know pawn pawn
fixed all of my stomach issues cuz you
have to get so in touch with your body
because it's not like a random hookup
where you can I mean obviously when
you're on a porn set things happen maybe
you have to cancel but for me like my
professionalism has been such a big part
of my brand that it's like if I'm booked
for an anal scene then you know you're
going to get an anal scene and I'm going
to be
clean cool is that but to get to that
that level like I've had to learn my
body like what any piece of food does to
my body how long it takes for me to like
for it to Transit like how it makes me
feel like the reactions that my body are
going to have like I've had to learn
everything so that I can know that yes
at 8:00 a.m. I'm going to be clean and
we can all day and there's going to be
no I'm so inspired